What about Miley Cyclops?
Damn it.
That's good.
I don't hate it.
She can shoot laser beams out of her eyes.
Shoots rays.
Billy Rays.
Tom, what are some forgotten Marvel superheroes
that you think deserve to be in the MCU?
I was kind of excited about this one.
So I think one of the big complaints that's
sort of been coming in about the MCU the last
few years has been just kind of the general
bloodlessness of it.
That was something that came up in a lot of
reviews for Black Widow, especially.
You've got the right, the scene where Florence
Pugh is explosion-proof.
She stabbed someone in the stomach and they're
like, "Oh!"
And then, she dies, but there's no blood.
Yeah.
As a general rule, anybody whose contract
isn't up is still going to be around by the
time that the credits roll.
There was this immensely bleak comic back
in the Eighties called Strikeforce: Morituri.
Have you ever heard of that?
No.
It is grim.
It was a Marvel comic.
It ran for a couple years back in the Eighties.
I think it only lasted 31 issues.
The concept is that Earth has been overrun
by aliens, and they're like these nasty ... It's
horrifying.
They're popping the heads off of kids to establish
dominance.
They're taking swaths of people up into the
upper atmosphere, and then releasing them
down so that they burn up as they reenter.
Jesus.
Yeah, no, it's really dark.
And then, this scientist comes up with this
kind of like last ditch attempt to maybe win
this war, and it's that he figures out a process
that gives people superpowers.
But the problem is that it only works on about
5% of people.
They got to be pretty young for it to work.
And, and if you do go through the process,
the stress that it puts on your body is going
to kill you within a year.
So it's this group of superpowered people
who know that whether they win this war or
not, they're going to die.
Oh my God.
Immensely grim.
Yeah, no, it's so dark.
Obviously, it wouldn't necessarily work within
like the MCU proper, but with them doing all
of the alternate universes, and the What Ifs,
and the different timelines, I don't know.
It could be kind of a cool standalone thing.
I don't know.
It would be interesting to see a story where
you don't know if the good guys are going
to win or not on a week-to-week basis.
It's sort of just a constant Ned Stark getting
killed at the end of the first season of Game
of Thrones, but just every week.
You never know.
Plus, you could probably get in a bunch of
great actors to do it if they know that they're
not devoting the next 10 years of their lives
to this one project that they got to keep
doing over and over again.
You said that they have to be young, though.
That's my question, could you hire any actor
to do it?
Could you play around with the age thing?
How young do they have to be?
So in the comics, the ideal age is 18 to 21.
Oh, cool.
Okay.
But the thing is that, they can put older
people through it, but the process will kill
them faster.
Oh.
Yeah, it's a really dark story.
So you could get a real A-lister in there
who's on the older side and be like, "Well,
you're just going to die really fast, so don't
worry about it."
Sure. Yeah.
I don't know.
I think that could be neat.
Yeah.
What's this called again?
Strikeforce: Morituri.
Was there any kind of lasting ramifications
on the Marvel universe after it wrapped up?
Practically none.
It got its own universe designation later
on down the line.
I think they made a couple of references to
it the last few years, maybe.
But yeah, no, it was just kind of thrown aside.
And it's weird, yeah, I haven't seen anybody
write anything about it, the last few years.
All right.
But, cool, weird, dark concept.
Definitely.
Alternately, my second choice would be NFL
SuperPro, who was-
I know SuperPro.
We all know SuperPro.
Back in the Nineties, there was a brief and
beautiful period where ex-NFL superstar, Phil
Grayfield, who blew out his knee, had a sports
injury, became a sports reporter, was interviewing
a super scientist/NFL fan, and received a
set of indestructible football uniform clothes.
Yeah, those exist.
During the interview, criminals break in and
rob the place.
And there's an explosion of science chemicals
and NFL memorabilia, which grant Phil Grayfield
the powers of the NFL SuperPro.
And he uses his sports powers to stop sports
crimes.
Right.
Introduces a lot of great characters.
You've got the super villains like Instant
Replay, who can travel in time just a little
bit.
Issue 10, you get to meet a guy, his superhero
name is the Almighty Dollar.
He gets the power to shoot pennies out of
his hands.
Generally considered one of the worst comics
ever made.
Wasn't it a tie-in?
Was it a licensing thing between Marvel and
the NFL?
It's half-and-half.
Half of the reason they haven't used the character
again is because of the licensing thing, and
then half of the reason is that it's the worst
idea that anybody's ever had.
A question; what's a sports crime?
What's a sports crime?
Stealing the the Stanley Cup?
I can't leave this conversation without knowing
what a sports crime is.
You know, I'm not going to sit here and mansplain
sports crimes to you.
I know about sports, but I don't what a sports
crime is.
I think we all know what a sports crime is.
Okay.
I don't recall.
I'm telling you I don't know.
Stealing first?
I don't know if you could ... You can't steal
first.
I mean, that would be a crime.
Stealing any base.
Oh, in football.
In football.
Yep.
Those are my picks.
I'm sorry, any further questions about NFL
SuperPro?
I was going to say, though, I mean, it's not
totally out of the picture, right, because
Disney owns ESPN?
And therefore, football.
That's right, yeah.
To a certain extent, yeah.
I mean, there's room for it to come back.
The sport of football.
Because ESPN does air some NFL games.
So maybe, as part of the rights package, next
time they renegotiate the project, they say-
Or.
... Yes?
Maybe the next time, the Super Bowl's on ABC.
They're like, "Let's bring him back."
That's right.
Halftime Show feature SuperPro.
Javier Bardem as NFL SuperPro.
The SuperPro Halftime Show.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, look at that.
This thing writes itself.
I mean, that was terrific.
Come on, ABC, write us a check.
Yeah.
Yes, please.
Finally.
We have so many good ideas.
Okay.
Nina, what are some forgotten Marvel heroes
that you think should be a part of the MCU?
Well, I only have the one, but I think it
comes with endless spinoff possibilities.
One is plenty.
I'm sure.
Perfect.
So in the 1990s, I believe the year was 1994?
Yes, it was a 1994 imprint through Marvel
called Marvel Music, and each issue was about
a different actual musician.
So they did The Rolling Stones.
They did Bob Marley, Alice Cooper.
And I'm not going to pick any of those because
those might be fun.
I'm going to pick Billy Ray Cyrus, who is
technically, legally, somehow a Marvel character
because he has one comic book.
So in this comic book, he rides around on
a horse a lot.
I think there's two distinct stories in it.
I tried reading it.
I couldn't get through it.
It's pretty bad.
At a certain point, I was like, "I have literally
a thousand better ways to spend my time."
But, the first-
Give us a broad strokes synopsis here.
What happens?
In one story that we could now ever do, now,
it is him fighting the ghost of a Native American
chief, using not the term Native American,
so problematic on a hundred different levels.
But the second one is similar to my dream
What If...? story, where he rides through
some ... He gets on a mysterious bus or something,
and he ends up in the 13th century, and he
has to slay a dragon.
Billy Ray Cyrus does.
Billy Ray Cyrus has to slay a dragon in the
13th century, yes.
This is a real Marvel comic, where Billy Ray
Cyrus fights a dragon in the thirteenth century?
That's correct.
Yes.
And like all of these start with-
He has the Achy Breaky Heart of a hero, Brian.
And all of these start with him walking around,
being Billy Ray, and people just run up to
him, and are like, "Oh my God."
And then, something weird happens.
So there's a weird, separate thread where
he just has people constantly running up to
him on the street and losing their minds.
But the reason that I picked Billy Ray Cyrus
is, first of all, easy casting.
He can play himself.
I mean, there's no dream casting here.
If they can afford him.
True.
But, would this open the door for Miley Cyrus
to be in the Marvel Cinematic Universe?
Maybe.
And that's something I'd much rather ... She's
already in it?
She's already in somewhere.
Wait, was she?
Was she?
She totally is.
Yeah, man.
Guardians of the Galaxy 2, when you get to
meet the original, Ravagers, the original
Guardians of the Galaxy, she plays the-
Okay.
You're right.
Well I'm saying has herself.
She does?
Yeah, dude.
Miley Cyrus?
So there's the original Guardians team with
with Sylvester Stallone.
There's like a robot head that you have talking
to them.
I can't remember the character's name.
Yeah, it's voiced by Miley Cyrus.
No.
Yeah.
Michael Rosenbaum's in there as the crystal
guy.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, Tom, you make a fair point, but I'm
saying I want her to be in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as herself.
As herself.
Yes.
As the daughter of Marvel character, Billy
Ray Cyrus.
Do you think that there's any room in this
story for her to have an auxiliary personality
that she, I don't know, maybe like a secret
persona, with which she ... I don't know.
Sorry.
I'm still reeling from the discovery that
Miley Cyrus is in Guardians of the Galaxy.
I think maybe, occasionally, she could wear
a wig and perform at pop concerts.
I'm not ruling anything out.
Now that's an idea.
I know.
We could do well with that.
But no, I mean, Miley Cyrus, I love watching
her do just about anything.
She's a very charismatic person.
So let's get the Billy Ray thing out the way,
and then, all of a sudden, boom, Miley Cyrus
playing herself in the MCU.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to jump on the fact that she
was already in there.
I just, I figured that the YouTube comments
are going to instantly fill up and didn't
want to let them beat us to the punch telling
us that we're wrong.
No, No, it's distinct.
You're right.
It's distinct enough.
She's not playing a robot head.
She's playing potential alien human being
Miley Cyrus because she's got the Bowie alien,
maybe you're not from this planet kind of
vibe going.
What would the name of her secret identity
be, if you had to make something up off the
top of your head?
I really didn't want you to ask me that because
I can't think of anything.
I'm trying to think of a planet pun.
Maybe like ... Got nothing.
Jenny Jupiter.
I think that one might be taken already.
We might need to check the copyright on that
one.
What about Miley Cyclops?
Damn it, that's good.
I don't hate it.
She can shoot laser beams out of her eyes.
Shoots rays.
Billy Rays.
Can you cut my terrible suggestion?
Thanks, editing team.
They're not going to cut it.
Okay.
I love this.
Now, Brian.
Yes?
Talk to us.
Yeah, what's your pick?
If I must.
You're the one that told us to be here today.
I have a couple picks.
One is, I think, a good pick, but it's irrelevant
now, but I'm going to say it anyway.
It's The Incredible Hercules.
Ooh.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hercules, I believe, was introduced in the
early days of Thor comics as yet another mythological
guy who hangs out in the Marvel universe.
And in the years since then, he's just kind
of become a lovable, affable large man who
goes on adventures and loves glory.
And so, there was this really great series
of comics when the Hulk was out of the picture
for a while, when he teamed up with a teen
genius, Amadeus Cho.
I believe it was called just The Incredible
Hercules, and they just go on adventures and
have a good time.
That sounds fun.
So, it is really fun.
It's a great comic book, but I think that
he's irrelevant now because they basically
turn Thor into him in the most recent Thor
movie.
Maybe a little bit.
So yeah, the current Thor is basically just
Incredible Hercules played by Chris Hemsworth.
Oh, gotcha.
Did they kind of merge the two characters?
I mean, just in terms of his general demeanor
because in the comics, Thor is still basically
just like big, strong-
Thunder god, yeah.
Thunder god, exactly.
And then, Taika Waititi got involved and made
him fun and silly.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Right.
And that's basically what Hercules is.
So, that would be what I would want to do.
But again, it's already basically been done.
So, that was my first pick.
So, I don't know if you know that on Twitter,
there's like a low-key campaign that's been
going on for about at least a year not to
get like-
A Loki campaign?
That's what I thought you said.
... Wakka wakka.
To get John Gabrus.
You know that guy?
No.
He's this great comic, really funny actor.
They're trying to get him cast as Hercules.
And he looks just like it.
I mean, it would work really well.
But like who would your dream casting for
that?
That was my question.
Who would be the dream casting?
Oh, I don't know.
I didn't think that far ahead.
Seth Rogan. I don't know. Why not?
Seth Rogan?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
This is the first person that came to my mind.
I have no clue.
I retract it.
Let's go back to Rowan Atkinson again.
Let's just make him.
Rowan Atkinson's a great choice for Hercules.
He should play every part in the MCU.
Thank you.
The Rowan Atkinson Cinematic Universe.
My other pick was the Great Lakes Avengers.
Perfect.
Fantastic.
Have we talked about them before?
No, I'm not familiar.
I don't know if we have together, but Yeah.
Yeah.
So there's the Avengers, and they live in
New York.
Then, there's the West Coast Avengers, and
they're out in like LA.
And then, as a joke, in the Eighties, I think
it was, there were the Great Lakes Avengers,
and they live here in the Midwest.
That's great.
I believe they were located in, I want to
say, Fond du Lac, Wisconsin.
And they consist of characters like Mr. Immortal,
who's superpower is that every time he dies,
he comes back to life, and that's it.
Sure.
So he dies frequently.
A lot.
Big Bertha, whose ability is to get very large.
What?
Flatman?
Right.
There's Flatman, who is flat.
Like Flat Stanley?
Like the thing that you have in middle school?
Not unlike Flat Stanley.
I don't know what that is.
Who's Flat Stanley?
She nailed it.
He's like Flatman.
Yeah, he's like Flatman.
Okay.
I guess that explains it.
Tom is the bridge between us.
Yeah.
Thank you, Tom.
So yeah, Flatman is basically like a crappier
Mr. Fantastic because instead of being able
to stretch, he's just very flat.
He's just flat.
Yes.
Dinah Soar, who is a dinosaur woman, and Doorman
who is just like a living door, so he can
teleport you, but you have to walk through
him.
And then, later on, back in the 2000s, they
added Squirrel Girl to the roster.
They're great.
They're fun.
They're funny.
I would love to see a Disney+ TV show of the
Great Lakes Avengers basically questioning
their very existence.
They fight no one.
They do nothing.
It's just a show about a bunch of superpowered
people who are not sure why they're here,
but they're making a go of it.
That was going to be my question is like,
who are their villains?
Who do they fight?
What do they do?
Nothing?
I don't know.
I think the story that I read that I remember
fondly, written by Dan Slott, I think they
fought Death itself if I remember correctly?
That's not where I saw that going.
I honestly don't remember, but I know they
save the world somehow.
They're just this unassuming Midwesterners,
and they fought Death itself.
Like, Jesus Christ, that's so metal.
Yeah.
They found a way.
So, yeah Great Lakes Avengers.
It's a great comic book, and, yeah, that's
my pick for that.
All right, now, cast them.
Cast it.
Okay.
I can't do much of this.
Squirrel Girl was already cast as Milana Vayntrub
for a show that never happened.
I know Mr. Immortal should be ... His name
has evaporated from my brain, but Kenneth
from 30 Rock.
What's his name?
Jack McBrayer.
Oh, Jack McBrayer.
Yeah.
Jack McBrayer, that's it.
I remembered immediately after I said it.
Terrific choice.
Thank you.
Because he's got a Southern drawl, and he
seems like the kind of person who could die
and get back up again and keep on going.
With that infectious grin.
Yeah.
Dinah Soar is just a purple dinosaur person.
No actor necessary.
So Barney.
Yeah.
Basically.
Flatman?
I don't know.
Let's go with Seth Rogan again.
Wow.
Big day for Rogan
I have no idea.
Yeah.
Seth, are you watching this?
You just booked so many roles.
I hope so.
You've booked em.
And let's just give Seth Rogan the rest of
them.
Seth Rogan and Rowan Atkinson can fill out
the rest of the team.
I don't know.
This has been a high effort day here at Looper.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like, and subscribe so you don't
miss a single episode.